[Music]
so GMOs we've asked about GMOs before
can you give me like a five minute sort
of GMO 101 yeah well free you say you
just say GMO people freak out they go
Monsanto and everyone goes now and
lately there's this added confusion
because of scientists who I've
interviewed many times across multiple
platforms named Kevin Fulton has been in
the news a lot because of a FOIA request
that revealed some things that people
didn't want to see mostly things that he
never denied anyway yeah but and it
wasn't a lot of money that he got and
all that but yes get complicated but but
regardless of that if we're gonna talk
about the core of GMOs these other
conversations really are irrelevant to
this core conversation so literally 101
sure focus know if you don't know
anything about yeah so what is it GMO
well technically the word genetically
modified organism could refer to
anything any organism anything that's
alive in which the genes have been
modified so basically breeding two
plants together to try and get a desired
trait is technically GMO now that's not
how we casually use the word anymore we
usually use the term GMO to actually
refer to transgenic organism so these
are organisms where they weren't
selectively bred for particular traits
but there was actually a trans gene that
was inserted we've gone into the
laboratory we've tested and we found
these genetic markers these areas where
we can do something to the plant
generally we're talking about plants
there are some animals that are up for
FDA approval like salmon mm-hmm but
generally we're talking about plants and
scientists will say for example this is
a big one right now citrus greening is
wiping out oranges in Florida wiping
them out they're all really sick it's
getting harder and harder to get fresh
oranges and this is a problem that they
don't see going away can we make oranges
that are resistant to this disease
because if we don't we may not have
oranges anymore so these scientists work
very hard to go into the genome to try
and understand all of these different
genes within the plant and try and
modify them in a certain way sometimes
it involves taking a gene from another
plant and inserting it sometimes it
involves turning a gene on silencing a
gene making a gene do something that
maybe it wouldn't have done unless it
was under pressure there's a lot of
different ways that
you can genetically modify a plant these
are things we've done for a long time
for all kinds of different plans oh yeah
and there are literally thousands of
research versions of GMOs but there are
very few GMOs that are on the market and
I think that's another big misconception
people you'll see you know labels on
crazy stuff like you'll see labels on
potatoes that are like GMO free and it's
like well yeah cuz there's no such thing
as a GMO food today like they're not
modifying it to stop either bugs from
eating I mean they are in the lab but
you can't buy it yet so the thing is the
only crops that are available are mostly
bigad crops so corn is is genetically
modified probably most of the corn that
you eat soy beans sugar beets papaya is
genetically modified a genetically
modified Apple just came on the market
or it's about to I think it's the
Okinawa Apple that and it doesn't Brown
you can take a bite out of it
did you try it it tastes like an apple
and you didn't like grow some weird I
did not we you know you've eaten a lot
of GMOs in your day and I don't see any
appendages that aren't supposed to be
there oh you can't see alright so from
that very sort of simplistic explanation
of what GMOs are why do so many people
hate GMOs because people are afraid of
what they don't understand and there's a
lot of misinformation out there and so
there are some legitimate concerns when
it comes to environmental consequences I
think probably the most legitimate
concern when it comes to GMOs is the is
a normal outcome of evolution and I use
the example of superbugs with
antibiotics because I think it's a good
analogy so when we take antibiotics we
actually induce resistance in the bugs
that can infect us and now there are
whole classes of bugs that are resistant
to those antibiotics just like in GMO
plants when you alter them to resist
certain pests or to resist mostly with
the pests when you alter them to resist
those pests you may have new pests that
Deval that evolve a resistance to that
resistance you see it a little bit with
weeds too like the glyphosate argument
which is round up people are really
scared of Roundup BT is more the pest
thing and the glyphosate is more of the
the weed thing
mix those things up that sort of
whatever Monsanto gets involved but
we'll cover that another time sure sure
we're talking about you know the
potential for super weeds to grow
because these plants are are helping
them grow it's it's a natural process
and it doesn't just happen in GM it
happens anytime that you're doing
large-scale agriculture and so I like to
say to people you know would you want to
take all the antibiotics off the market
because they're making antibiotic
resistant no we need to be smarter about
how we use them and we need to come up
with new antibiotics and so what
scientists are actually doing is they're
trying to figure out new and better ways
to improve resistance to these different
bugs let's say that there is a pesticide
inside of a plant and the bug develops
resistance to that pesticide well if you
actually alter that plant in two ways
now you have two lines of defense
against this bug it's statistically very
unlikely that you'll get a mutation in
that bug against both of those lines of
resistance so now you can have a
resistant plant and you're less likely
to see resistance occurring in the bug
so you know scientists are always trying
to keep one step ahead of nature and
these are the biggest problems that
we're seeing with genetic modification a
lot of the problems that people think
are happening with genetic modification
cancer you know health problems what's
the big one seeds blowing into another
field and getting sued for it
that's the months yes suicides in India
yeah none of these are substantiated
yeah none of them the science shows time
and time again that these are not real
concerns and if you actually do dig into
the case law and you actually do try and
understand what has happened legally in
these situations most of those lawsuits
with the big AG companies involve people
storing seeds which is technically
against the law now if you have a
problem with you know patenting a see
right again it's a or if you have a
problem with large-scale agribusiness
and you have a problem with the way that
we you know dry out the land by only
farming a very particular crop I get
that but that has nothing to do with
genetic modification and I think we
often conflate the
[Music]